dane dunning
on the mound for the rangers tonight
trending in the right direction overall
the era was up at 471
back on june 20th and he has slowly
chipped away at that
breaking ball on that one lined out
there near second base kinder philippa
shaded over from shortstop reels that
one in and there are two gone
and there's a bouncing ball to shortstop
kind of falafel hustles it over in time
and they get goslin
and so dane dunning another spotless
first inning they watched chris and his
workload very closely on the farm this
year he is ready to go to work to open
his first ever major league starting
assignment
there's a drive well hitting the left
it's going to hang into the corner
however for juan lagares to close on it
and record the first out the bottom of
the inning
one gone for nate lowe
and he wastes no time with the ground
ball for david fletcher
garcia behind owen two and a one
two three start to the career
of chris rodriguez as a big league
starting pitcher
and he hits this one on the ground up
the middle sliding stopped by bonyas the
throw from the seat of his pants in time
wow what a play that was a great play
just to get to the ball
and then i wasn't sure he'd have enough
on the throw he had plenty
and he beat stassi by quite a little bit
at first big
swing and a miss and marsh strikes out
first drink out of the night for dunny
two away
and a ground ball up the middle and past
connor falefa into center field
back to back two out singles here in the
angel second
it took a really good play by ivanya's
at second to prevent three hits in this
inning
swinging a slow ground ball to second
charge by ebanya's
over the first two and the inning
here comes the 1-2 delivery
that one got him exactly where it got it
now becomes the question when you get
hit up there
tends to worry a manager and a player so
he says he's okay
let's see if he gets something here
three and one and that ball hit hard
down the left field line and that will
be extra bases for curtis terry
habanes to third they'll throw up the
stop sign
a stand-up double and curtis terry
is in the book somebody get that
baseball his first big league hit
and it was clean and loud now a chance
for brock holt to maybe cash in a couple
here
that one gets away from rodriguez here
comes the bagnes he'll score easily
and terry goes to third once we got away
from rodriguez
it hits stassi though in the glove and
the angels
have just gifted the rangers a run
3-0 pitch and that's ball four
rocks holt on four pitches after curtis
terry's
double didn't look like c-rod was going
gonna have to work this hard this inning
after he got the quick out on jonah heim
that's into right field coming on as
eaton he dives
and saves a couple of runs in the
process
a fine sliding catch by adam eaton
saved two with that play
[Music]
oh swinging them in so tony strikes out
two in the inning that's a nice one to
have in your book
absolutely dane dunning continues to do
it nice sinker down
in the zone gets otani swinging
oh and two to connor falefa made him
chase and it's a three pitch strikeout
that opens the last of the third
but when you get a hitter to swing at
that one below the strike zone that is a
special pitch
that one spun him around chasing that
sinker and the
inning is over good inning for rodriguez
2-2 pitch and stasi sends it back up the
middle
a base hit that advances gosling and
here come the halos in the fourth and
the fourth rather first
and second with nobody out second and
third with one gun one nothing texas
we'll see what juan logaris can do on
the ground to shortstop that will get a
run home
lagara is credited with the rbi as the
angels tie it this one line to short
and kinder phileta able to go up and get
it
whips here and that's another strikeout
for
rodriguez so the young right hand are
starting to look pretty good
this guy rodriguez their second best
pitching prospect in the organization
and he's pitching well here tonight that
gives him a little hope going forward to
bounce her over to the first base side
and that's an easy
put out of mark brock walked in that
second inning beginning which the ranger
scored
outside of that that second inning
rodriguez has been perfect this one
lined in the left field by holt got a
good stride out of the box
he's trying to stretch it for two and he
is in there a one out double
for brock holt his 11th this year three
and two the count holt at second one out
ty baughey
and the pitch ball four as rodriguez
misses low
and it brings up nathaniel lowe
double steel attempt they come into the
plate hold he is in there
stassi threw down the second base
apparently
he convinced he could get kinder
philippa otherwise i
i oftentimes question why try because
you
know that holt's gonna break from third
and the rangers steal a run
here's the pitch and there's a swing and
a miss and the inning ends
on the strikeout but on the delayed
double steal the rangers
have taken a 2-1 lead
matt wieder's yasmani grand all heim is
rung up here that's
six for chris rodriguez tonight
his minor league strikeout high this
year with six
and that's his seventh of the night
tonight another one two three inning
chris rodriguez dominant in arlington
tonight yet still trailing by a run
[Applause]
this one hit sharkly out into right
field that's a base hit from martin
he'll turn and go for two eaton just
coming up with it
martin slams on the brakes at second
that ball
head hard out the center field marsh
coming in he won't get to it it drops in
for a base hit
so i think marsh and i
[Music]
might have overestimated that one six
plus from chris rodriguez in his first
career major league start
and the bullpen will try to hold it at a
one run deficit on his behalf
all in all a terrific night for c rod
so it'll be up to mike myers and the
angels bullpen
brock holt at the plate with minute
first and third and nobody out
and that one hit well out to right
center that'll be
deep enough at the very least to get one
home marsh makes the catch martin tags
he'll score heading to second and it
just in there is curtis terry
how has it gambled on terry's part my
goodness
but he moves up the base on the sac fly
by holt
it's now three to one and that'll take
us back to the top of the order and
isaiah keiner for lethal
swinging a line drive base hit into
center field terry hits the bag at 30s
being waved home marshes up with the
throw
but it's cut at second they throw behind
connor falefa and have him caught in a
rundown
the throw goes to iglesias near second
he applies the tag
and the inning is over terry scored on
the play though credit kyner falef with
a run scoring single
it's 4-1 texas and the rangers trying to
keep them down here in game one spencer
patton on looking for the save
one-two pitch and a swing and a miss
strike three he strikes out stassey
two-guard
is this one in the air center field
hang it up and white has it that will
end it the rangers take the opener
from the angels four to one